but
uh can we talk about uh
darkness a little bit so yeah yeah ted
kaczynski the unabomber was allegedly
part of the mk ultra studies
while at harvard uh do you think this is
true
do you think had an impact on him
psychologically intellectually
and so on i do think it's true and i do
think i it had an impact so
we talked before about are these drugs
somehow rather um
producing a certain kind of drug
experience or do they bring out what's
within
so we have this experience yeah on the
one hand ken kesey and he
sort of took positive things out of this
on the other hand
you know we can get this uh
opposition to the modern world to
technology and to the point of
creating bombs to try to go after it so
that
the experience is not in the drug it's
this interaction between
the drug the person the context and so
we can heal people with psychedelics or
people can be driven crazy with
psychedelics
it depends again on the context and so
i think it's both these things can be
true and i think it was really good that
you kind of
highlighted this that there is this
polarities
and that it's not in the drug it's in
the the
other factors and it's who they were
beforehand and then how you use that
experience so
all that's to say is if we put lsd in
the water and everybody we're going to
get it
it doesn't mean that all of a sudden
everybody's going to have a mystical
experience and then that's
you know all we need to do and humanity
is spiritualized or
end war and all of this it's it's not
about
the drug that actually is why for me
um we've also talked about
engineering new psychedelics and all the
people that are going to be trying
for-profit companies to develop and
patent new psychedelics
for me the most important challenge is
new cultural contexts
that can create legality safety support
for the existing psychedelics that we
already have
i mean we have so much incredible
tools in these existing psychedelics
that
it's more about creating context for
them to be used in safe medical or
personal
growth or recreational even with harm
reduction all these different ways
that's more important to me than
finding some new molecule that's
somewhat similar somewhat different but
you know it can be patented so it's the
social context
so i i do believe that ted kaczynski was
part of nk ultra and i think it affected
him in a negative way
and that's a cautionary tale that it's
not in the drug it's in the context
the context the person still it feels
like
if viewed from a therapy perspective
perhaps there was a way to use
psychedelics to help
ted kaczynski find a path out of the
darkness
i i think so and i think that um
this is where i think mdma comes in in a
way that
mdma is you know he felt very isolated
and
very much out of society in some ways
um mdma stimulates oxytocin which we
haven't mentioned which is the hormone
of nursing mothers of love and
connection it provides a lot of this
sense of self-acceptance and safety and
and wanting to be in relationship
there's google dolan is a neuroscientist
at hopkins she's given octopuses mdma
they're solitary creatures except mating
season which is not very often
and but you give them mdma and they
become more interested in hanging out
with other octopuses
so i think this um for people that have
had difficult psychedelic experiences
mdma helps them integrate them we've
worked with people that had
a difficult lsd experience 40 years
before
and are still able to get back to that
under the influence of mdma and work out
some of the conflicts
that they weren't able to resolve all
those decades before
so i think that psychedelics could have
been helpful
in a different context for ted kozinski
but the other
big part of it is that people have to be
willing to cooperate with the experience
we talked about resistance
so people can resist these things it's
you know the saying is you can drink
bring bring a horse to water but you
can't make them drink this is about how
people have to be willing to go to these
spaces so
one of the essence of our therapeutic
approach is that we
help people to heal themselves that we
are not
giving them the healing it's it's a flip
on the power dynamics
that existed you would say in the 50s
and 60s my dad was a doctor and the
doctors were gods and you know
whatever they said was right and you
know we no longer of course believe that
but
um for a while psychoanalysis with freud
you know
that they gave the interpretation to the
patient the patient couldn't help
themselves but they would do the free
associations and the
psychoanalysts would see these conflicts
and would would be the one that does the
healing
would give this interpretation and that
would open things up so
i i think it's this idea of empowering
people to heal themselves
and so if ted kazinsky had been in a
therapeutic setting with psychedelics
and if they'd had something like mdma
available or mda which was popular
during the 60s which is more like mdma
lsd combination
the outcomes might have been different
you